here oh Debo was absolutely incredible I
feel like he's my son I love this kid so
much thank
you coach Mr Davis that man challenged
you this year to be the best leader you
could possibly be you said it took you a
little out of your comfort zone looking
at it now what do you think of that
challenge
oh no
put in a lot of work
because
[Music]
what makes you tear up what are you
thinking about
let's put in the work
his team is struggling and we we figured
it out
and I'm glad we did at the right time
and hopefully we continue to do it
you earned it you enjoy every second of
this young man thanks congratulations
from Jacksonville Arkansas can you
imagine
playing for the Razorbacks always
dreamed of it was a defensive specialist
but they kept saying his offensive game
is coming
and he shines like no other with 21
second half points Devoe Davis 25.
in this second round performance